you
talk about being a boss obviously you
got eagle uh is that
like are both of you guys looking to
sign artists or have you signed any
artists or is that something that's even
true you guys are still quote-unquote
new artists
but you know you came up under nipsey
who you know
obviously laid the blueprint for a lot
of [ __ ] that a lot of rappers are doing
nowadays is that something you guys are
interested in getting into
most definitely um i'm actually working
with an artist right now but
we just it's in the works right now i
don't i want to roll it out the right
way for sure but
shout out j million for sure oh fire
what what is
what do you look for like in an artist
like if you
if you make that decision to put your
stamp on an artist like what is the
what are the qualities man my main thing
is just
not having to tell somebody what to do
you know so that
that natural work ethic and just
consistency
and of course talent of course but just
not having a
look at it yeah babysit exactly and i
feel like that's that's what i want him
around me you know man yeah it's tough
because you know you have an artist that
has all the talent in the world
yeah but unless they're told what to do
they're just gonna sit at home and play
nba 2k call of duty or some [ __ ] you
know okay
yeah shout out to artists again what are
we saying j j million j
million okay from out here yeah